china is getting nervous a vast
quarantine center
under construction in herbei province
which borders beijing
the government has ordered every other
province in the country to make similar
preparations
millions of people are being tested
multiple times
and millions have been locked down and
this is a proper lockdown
this man left his house for a walk and
was verbally abused and tied to a tree
for his trouble
with such extreme measures you might
think that china is being overwhelmed by
a second wave
the extraordinary thing is it's barely a
dribble
on friday the country recorded just 103
new cases it has fewer than 2 000 in
total
despite that low number the restrictions
seem to have the support of the eleven
million residents under lockdown in
shijajuang
the capital of herbert
in beijing there are only three new
confirmed covert cases today
but this is what happens as a result
more than two million people have been
ordered to take a test by sunday
the cues snake through the narrow
alleyways of the old neighborhoods
it is exactly a year on from the very
first lockdown in wuhan
kovit has been controlled here and still
china is not letting its guard down
right now there is no end in sight
[Music]
even apart from the testing and the
lockdowns covert prevention measures are
now part of daily life
communities have shut their doors only
allowing entry to people with negative
tests
vaccines are being targeted not at the
most vulnerable but those most likely to
interact with others
mainly workers and smartphones have
become passports
it is now impossible to enter most
buildings without showing a health code
which tracks your movements across china
so this is what
getting a taxi involves now scanning the
health kit
getting the green signal and that's the
case for everything you can see the
plastic screen here
and every driver on this ride hailing
service is now being
encouraged to get a vaccination shuffle
nidalee meow
so he's had his vaccine already
china has boasted very publicly of his
success in controlling kovid
and credited those achievements to the
leadership of the chinese communist
party
so put simply things cannot be allowed
to get out of control
tom cheshire sky news beijing